that polarization is almost entirely the
creation of a media elite who believe
themselves to be part of a new ruling
class
who get to dictate to you how to live
they know better than you how to live
and if you agree with them
then you are one of the elect and if you
disagree with them then you are a member
of the damned
this starts by the way at our
universities there's an article in the
new york times called inside a battle
over race
class and power at smith college and
this is just indicative
of how our society really works because
colleges are basically just a microcosm
a slightly more extreme microcosm of
what's happening in corporate america
of what is happening even in the
scientific community the shutdown of
science that is currently happening
in the publishing community the war on
openness of ideas
is ongoing and dangerous so according to
the new york times
in mid-summer of 2018 umu knute a black
student at smith college and i apologize
if i'm mispronouncing the name recounted
a distressing american tale
she was eating lunch in a dorm lounge
when a janitor and a campus police
officer walked over
and asked her what she was doing there
the officer who could have been carrying
a lethal weapon left her near meltdown
ms knute wrote on facebook
saying that this encounter continued a
year-long pattern of harassment at smith
all i did was be black ms knute wrote
it's outrageous that some people
question my being at smith college and
my existence overall as a woman of color
the college's president kathleen
mccartney offered profuse apologies and
put the pen
the janitor on paid leave the janitor
this painful incident reminds us of the
ongoing legacy of racism and bias the
president wrote
in which people of color are targeted
simply while going about the business of
their ordinary lives
the new york times washington post cnn
picked up the story of a young female
student harassed by white workers
the aclu which took the student's case
said she was profiled
for eating while black less attention
was paid three months later when a law
firm hired by smith college to
investigate the episode found
no persuasive evidence of bias
oh interesting less attention was paid
this is in the new york times
note this happened again in mid-summer
of 2018 the date
of this article the one i'm reading
right now is february 24th 2021
and yet we knew three months later that
the story was bullcrap did the new york
times printer retraction of course not
did the new york times go back and
report the story of course not did cnn
do that did the washington post do that
no because they are dedicated to the
narrative that america is a place of
deep and abiding racism
and that anybody who opposes that
narrative is in fact it
opposing the narrative is itself a sign
that you are racist
opposing the narrative suggesting that
america is not systemically racist that
america is a land of liberty
filled with decent people that that is a
sign that you are a bigot
you're probably one of those trump
supporters according to the new york
times less attention was paid three
months later when a law firm hired by
smith college to investigate the episode
found no persuasive evidence of bias ms
canute was determined to have eaten in a
deserted dorm
that had been closed for the summer the
janitor had been encouraged to notify
security if he saw unauthorized people
there
the officer like all campus police was
unarmed so every single element of the
story was a lie
every single one this person insisted in
eating in a deserted
dorm hall that was supposed to be closed
the janitor had been instructed to tell
people
if somebody tried to eat in there and
the officer was unarmed and according to
this
woman's story she went to eat like a
normal dorm hall the janitor profiled
her for being black and an armed officer
came and threatened her
so every element was a lie smith college
officials
emphasized reconciliation and healing
after the incident in the months to come
they announced a raft of anti-bias
training for all staff a revamped and
more sensitive campus police force and
the creation of dormitories
as demanded by ms canoon and her aclu
lawyer set aside for black students and
other students of color by the way if
you want just a case study
and the perversion of liberalism into
hardcore leftists just take a look at
the aclu the aclu used to be the people
who suggested that yes we hate the kkk
but they have a right to march through
the jewish areas of skokie
now the aclu are the people who are like
you know what we should separate dorm
rooms for the sensitivity
of black students and make sure that we
have segregated dorm facilities
the aclu are the people who say that
they will not defend they literally say
this they will not defend civil
liberties
if those civil liberties come into
conflict with higher priorities of
sensitivity
they are literally the opposite of a
civil liberties union at this point
it demonstrates the shift from
liberalism to leftism and how you leave
behind
all of the priorities you used to hold
so long as you are in the search for
utopia
according to the new york times they did
not offer any public apology or amends
to the workers whose lives were gravely
disrupted by the students accusation
this is a tale of how race class and
power collided at the elite 145 year old
liberal arts college or tuition room and
board top 78 thousand dollars a year
and where the employees who keep the
school running often come from working
class
enclaves beyond the school's elegant
wrought iron gates the story highlights
the tensions between a student's deeply
felt sense of personal truth
and the facts that are at odds with it
my god the way that the new york times
phrase is that
the story highlights the tension between
a deeply felt sense of personal truth
and fact that are at odds with it okay
translate that over to the q anon folks
and see if the new york times goes along
with that you know there are people who
have a deeply felt sense of personal
truth about the q anon conspiracy theory
but there are facts at odds with it and
there's tension there or is it that
you're completely wrong
and lying and you believe a bunch of
horse crap and
there are facts that disprove this which
makes you a liar
a liar because facts exist in real life
and the new york times reported the lie
for years and only three years later are
they coming back around like well you
know i guess that
you know there is a tension between your
personal truth and actual fact
these tensions says the new york times
come at a time when few and the smith
community
feel comfortable publicly questioning
liberal orthodoxy on race and identity
and some professors worry the
administration is too deferential so
it's increasingly emboldened students
right because why would you question the
liberal orthodoxy
if you if you question liberal orthodoxy
then you become
one of the people with a target on your
back james miller econ professor at
smith
says my perception is if you're on the
wrong side of issues of identity
politics you're not just mistaken
you're evil correct correct and that
perception has spread
throughout the liberal community which
is why you see that stat that
the highest percentage of any percentage
of democrats who believe that there's a
problem believe that the problem is
trump supporters and white nationalism
in an interview miss mccartney said that
miss knuts encounter with the campus
staff was part of a spate of cases of
living while black harassment across the
nation there was she noted great
pressure to act
we always try to show compassion for
everyone involved not um
not the janitor at the general who's
probably making 20 grand a year
that guy got in serious trouble for
doing nothing wrong
faculty members pointed to a pattern
they say reflects the college's growing
timidity in the face of allegations from
students especially around the issue of
race and ethnicity in 2016
students denounced faculty at smith's
social work program as racist
after some professors questioned whether
admission standards for the program had
been lowered and this was affecting the
quality
of the field work dennis meals one of
the professors they decried left the
school long after because you're not
even allowed to point out that when you
put in place affirmative action programs
it lowers the standards of admission
that is what affirmative action programs
are deliberately designed to do
if people had to meet the exact same
standard you wouldn't have to have
affirmative action programs
affirmative action programs are
deliberately designed to lower standards
through the soft bigotry of low
expectations in order to achieve
the proper racial balance but if you
point that out you probably should
you should be forced to leave because
looking truth directly in the face is
not allowed
then in the autumn of 2019 the religious
studies department proposed a class on
native american religion and
spirituality
a full complement of students registered
but well before classes began
a small contingent of native american
students and allies pasted bright red
posters on buildings on campus reviling
the course
as harmful intrusive and disrespectful
and attacking the instructor who was
young white and not on a tenure track
he had an academic background in this
field and has modeled his course on that
of his mentor who was a well-known
professor and member of the choctaw
nation
the administration declined to challenge
the student protesters had the
instructor submit to sessions of radical
listening with the protesters and
the religious studies department dropped
the class
all of this is disgusting and terrible
but it does not matter the new york
times still treats the original story as
worthwhile of respect
which it turned out to be crap by the
way
the janitor is the one who's the actual
victim in this story the janitor who was
in his 60s and poor of sight was
emptying garbage cans when he noticed
someone in a closed lounge all involved
with the summer camp were required to
have state background checks on campus
police
had advised staff it was wisest to call
security rather than confront strangers
on its own
the janitor dialed security the janitor
did not notice
did not note the ladies rays
miss canoe was in the shadows he was not
sure if he was looking at a man or a
woman
later knute would accuse the janitor of
misgendering her
a well-known older campus security
officer drove over to the dorm
recognized canute as a student they had
a brief and play conversation which she
recorded
he apologized for bothering her she
spoke to him of her discomfort
that night she wrote a facebook post and
the college took it so seriously that
they basically
decided they were going to can everybody
involved i mean all of this is just
indicative of where we are as a society
it's indicative of how our society works
and it's terrible again it's it's
it's just insanity okay the
the the treatment of the story as
anything remotely approaching realistic
is insanity
three weeks after the incident at tyler
house miss blair a cafeteria worker
received an email from a reporter at the
boston globe
asking her to comment on why she called
security for ms canood for eating while
black this puzzled her what did she have
to do with anything
the next morning the food services
director called
jackie he said you're on facebook knut
had posted her name
photograph and email along with the
janitor's
name photograph and email canute said
that blair was the racist and said that
the janitor was also a racist
blair has lupus she felt faint
she lives with her husband a mechanic
and makes 40 grand a year
smith put out a short statement noting
that blair had not placed the phone call
to security but did not absolve her of
broader responsibility
somebody at the administration called
the again this is like an unrelated
cafeteria worker who's now getting death
threats
because of all of this but don't worry
this is just about the tension between
some people's version of truth and you
know the truth okay so here's the thing
this is now bled over into every element
of our society because the narrative
matters more than the fact
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe
button so you stay up to date on all of
our future content